today we're going to talk about
something that is just so nuts to me
that anyone would do let alone a big
huge company that can easily be fact
checked like you're just out here lying
in a way that is damaging like to a lot
of people and it's just dishonest for
what but then from there I also wanted
to talk about some similar lies that are
occurring in the games industry that I
feel like I am seeing Gamers fall for
that I just wanted to take the time to
demystify a little basically big
companies keep lying about the tech
they're using and what it can do which
is like unsurprising cuz that's a big
company's going to big company for the
first topic film in case you missed it
Greta Go's bobie very accomplished
claims to have filmed a bunch of scenes
without CGI they even presented a sort
of making of documentary where they
claim to show how certain things in the
film were done with no CGI this Yahoo
news article Falls for it even though it
is like very easily proven to be untrue
hi yes Hello by now you probably know
that Bobby is the biggest movie of 2023
I don't know how else you read something
that starts like that while moving
between Bobby land in the real world I
can't keep that up I'm going to die on
the inside Bobby and Ken travel through
a bunch of different scenes using a car
boat spaceship bicycle Campa van and
Snowville before rollerblading in Venice
Beach and this section of the movie did
look really cool I love that it has like
the toy box aesthetic I think that's
something that this movie nailed it
looks rad so yeah they just keep doing
these like different versions of Bobby
sets where they're dressed inappropriate
B attire bobing through the land to get
from Bobby land to Venice Beach Venice
Beach truly the Pinnacle of the world
nobody likes it there while it's a fun
transition Montage every single time it
happens what makes it even better is how
it was filmed namely it was all done
practically on set using some old school
movie Magic they've got little images
here showing how they were held up by
strings instead of having the actors
film these moments on a green or blue
screen and have the elements CGI and
later Bobby elected to build sets and
backdrops which helped give the
two-dimensional feeling that is seen in
the Finish scenes now again I'm going to
show it to you but why would you lie
about this obviously because CGI is lazy
cheap man's way to make film oh we turn
our noses up at CGI disgusting hang on I
need to move my camera back over so you
can't see my fake cyberpunk background I
mean no that's all real it's all
definitely real now there are certainly
things that I do not like about overuse
of CGI I prefer a lot of things being
done practically things being done in a
way that's painted I'm certainly one of
the people uh that is kind of getting
sick of the volum so much of Star Wars
started to look the same it looked
really empty because they're using the
volume which a lot of you will have seen
it's very very very cool Tech you can't
use it everywhere and there are
certainly downsides to overuse of CGI
George Lucas do you know what I mean but
also a reality of CGI and uh most people
who talk about there being no CGI is
actually that it takes a lot of people a
lot of effort to get right there are so
many people in so many visual effects
departments who work incredibly hard on
making CGI backgrounds work that are
raising them just just sucks like it's
just not only are you lying to customers
to I don't know again pretend that you
don't have CG you're also diminishing
the hard work of people who like put so
much effort into this like it's a it is
a CH a technical challenge okay and this
is basically one of those Industries
that's very similar to game development
in my opinion is when you do CGI really
really well nobody notices you'll only
notice when it's bad this also totally
happens in Game Dev it's really
difficult to tell when somebody has done
something well because the point is that
it's completely seamless and not at all
noticeable which is clearly What's
happen with a lot of these movies that
are claiming no CGI and I guess the
thing is we're currently at a point
where CGI often is so good that for all
the times you can say you hate CGI you
don't want CGI in movies so much of it
is just already so good that most people
don't even notice it half the movies
that are praise for not having CGI like
top gun Maverick get points on the
reviews because they didn't use CGI but
actually they did it's just a blend of
practical and CGI for the record I
learned about all of this through a
YouTube channel that's called uh the
movie movie Rabbit Hole credit to them
for literally all of this I'm going to
leave a link in the description to their
series that is no CGI is just invisible
CGI I highly recommend you watch that
videos way way way more detailed than
any of the context I will be giving here
um but it is really interesting stuff
let me show you a little bit about top
gun Maverick it turns out a lot of the
aircraft they filmed practically were
not the aircraft you see in the final
film instead they filmed these l39
standing Jets painted them gray and
added tracking markers so they could be
used for lighting reference and track
the good old F14 it's all CGI the
enemy's fifth generation Fighters they
don't exist they're all CGI which means
that in the entire dog fight at the end
of the movie you're watching 100% CGI
airplanes because none of these planes
exist so this is certainly a thing that
keeps happening now to jump to Bobby
specifically this is the thing that I
think is like exceptionally gross okay
this scene was filmed on blue screen
there is a blue screen here and you can
see they've badly removed it and
inserted the desert background to and
then again you can spot the blue screen
keying and he's right you can see it you
can see it in Ken's hair you can see it
in the backgrounds and then they claim
in their own making of that none of this
exists there are photos of blue screens
being used on this set one Brothers has
done a complete blue screen removal on
45 minutes of bonus material it's nuts
and the thing about this that I think I
find the wildest is that if you look in
the Bobby credits you can see lists of
people's names in the VFX Department
like why are we pretending that those
people just don't exist so this is a
thing they will also do in behind the
scenes photos if you see behind the
scenes photos of Actis on sets with blue
screens they will usually edit them to
be gray so that it looks like a studio
you can even see the color on her hair
here this is clearly not gray there is
color seeping through from a blue
background that is a blue reflection
coming off of hair you can't really hide
the reflection of a blue screen in a lot
of cases there you go perfect example
this is all blue screen you can see the
blue around here but for some reason
they can't let the people know no CGI
really just means no bad CG GI at this
point and what that means in my opinion
is that the people who are doing this
work deserve even more credit like
they've made something that's so good
that you can't tell that it's there that
the companies who are marketing these
movies are comfortable saying there's no
CGI because the people who are doing
this type of bfx work are so talented at
this point doesn't that mean they should
get more credit not less credit is that
such a crazy stance basically you're
effectively being lied to in most of
these things R CGI even if CGI as a
phrase doesn't really apply it's more
just VFX it's a lie it's marketing and
so nuts that we are dismissing all of
the hard work of all of these people now
as this pertains to video games what's
happening right now at video games is
actually almost the opposite obviously
we know that video games are not real I
know shocking new information I'm
presenting you with today but the
current swoop of AI is heading in an
opposite direction with the same intent
that the no CGI marketing is in the film
industry you remember nfts you remember
when everybody was trying to put those
in video games you mean that I can ruin
the thing I love by making it entirely
monetized it was actually so funny to me
to watch all of these companies be like
I don't gam as will love this it will
improve video games cuz it just tells
you these CEOs have like no concept of
why Gamers actually like to play video
games which is because they enjoy them I
have a family friend who has said
something vaguely similar to me he's
like why aren't you getting in on nft
gaming oh like every friend I have who's
worked in nft gaming who's been laid off
but there's so much money Alana you
should know how are you not doing it
yeah it's because Gamers don't actually
find that appealing at all just CEOs do
and it's yeah it's just really funny to
watch people not understand the concept
of fun like Gamers don't want to have to
play something as a second job or a
Marketplace so they really tried and
realized that it wouldn't work and so
now the push from all of these startups
which in many cases are the same people
who had failed nft gaming companies is
for AI Gamers don't seem to mind AI as
much you may have seen asmin gold went
sort of viral for saying this recently
if it was made with AI I'm completely
okay with that because it was fun
artists opinions don't matter it just
doesn't matter matter because what
matters is the opinion of the people
that are buying the product Oh so if you
don't know asold is a big blizzard
streamer mostly I think and people are
very upset with him for saying this like
almost canceled him for saying this um
even though he is ultimately correct the
opinion of the artists does not matter
the market will dictate whatever it
wants to do regardless of the opinion of
the artists is the reality when it comes
to sales and power well being successful
people are still going to play it if it
is fun they're not going to care that
artists don't like it I actually think
that like as my stance on AI I think you
have to make up your own decision pick
and choose what you want it's going to
get messy out here where generative AI
is concerned there are certain things
that I personally will not play uh you
have to make your own choice for me I
don't want to play something that has
art that was AI generated that has
writing that was completely AI generated
or that has music that was completely AI
generated that is my stance maybe I
won't even be able to hold off on that
for very long hopefully we can but my
attitude personally is like what is the
point in even existing like literally
what's the point in being human if not
to at least experience culture or
Community you know that's how I feel
about it you have to make your own
choice about what you do and don't want
to play but within this framework there
is so much misinformation that is coming
from these same shitty nft Bros who are
trying to sell you on how amazing games
can be if they just use AI because
they're trying to make you accept it
even though in a lot of cases a games
already use AI every single video game
already uses AI I don't know how we've
forgotten that the word AI is being
thrown around as some net negative even
though video games have been using AI
for a very very very long time B there
are a lot of things that companies are
trying to sell to you that video game
developers can already actually do this
like it's so obvious to me that they're
just trying to sneak in AI to get a
quick Buck from any company they can
while it's still hot because the nfts
didn't work like it's the same [__]
people genuinely look it up literally
the same names the founders of these
companies it's so nuts this is an
article from The Verge about nvidia's
new AI NPCs I'm a huge fan of Nvidia I
have their graphics cards then pushing
aite Tech is hugely beneficial to them
as a company same as nfts were actually
Nvidia makes so much hardware and
there's so much Tech that is dependent
on their exact kind of Hardware but
there's this particular part of this
article that people were calling out on
Game Twitter that I think is really
interesting the article talks about them
trying the Nvidia Ai and that it wasn't
actually very good at this point in time
but goes on to say I can now absolutely
imagine games where NPCs remember what
they've seen and react to the game
scripts as it unfolds the right bits
could enter their memory bank at the
right time get filtered through their
personality and desires and make a game
more immersive and interactive as a
result we can already do this in video
games this is already available in
development tools this does not need
some new AI I Tech in fact that's the
case for half of the things that people
are claiming AI will be able to do or at
the very least that AI Tech has already
existed people keep talking about it
with Grand Theft Auto they're trying to
patent I think Rockstar is trying to
patent some new technology that would
allow for more immersive reaction say
you know how in um previous gtas if it
rains they might pull up a newspaper to
cover their head or maybe if they have
an umbrella they'll use it they're
trying to combine that body language
with the weather effect with maybe that
particular NPC being in a certain mood
this does not require any new AI Tech
this is not some recent breakthrough
this is something that literal Game Dev
tools can already facilitate it's being
spoken about as though it's some new
thing this is just how game development
is able to function and has always been
able to function as long as people have
the the room and the ideas to iterate
but that's not some new AI is going to
replace everybody in video games thing
that is still somebody coming up with
those systems this stuff does not
require generative AI which is the thing
that I am talking about personally being
against which thankfully Verge did
mention here is we can already as game
developers use these things to augment
games that's way that's half of what
Game Dev is is making sure that when
this person reaches this place and this
thing happens that they remember this
thing also happened it can still be very
complicated and AI can still make
mistakes with that kind of stuff as well
but it's not some new thing but yes we
we don't want any of it replacing voice
voice actors writers or artists again
you're going to have to decide what your
personal stance is do whatever you want
with that but it's just so bizarre to
watch these things basically be
repackaged as some shiny new tech that's
going to make video games better for
players when it's stuff that all already
exists like this is just nonsense it's
not even generative AI it's basically
just another silly little bubble don't
let them fool you do I think some of
these companies will succeed yes do I
think that what Asma goldd said is
correct that the opinions of the artist
ultimately don't matter yes and it was
almost surprising to see him get that
much backlash for it it's like it sucks
like they should but but financially
they don't matter the industry will go
wherever the money is regardless of what
anyone thinks about it which is why I
say make up your own mind what kind of
AI you are or are not against no part of
it is hypocritical to be okay with some
things and not okay with other things
because they are in such bossly
different categories basically I just
like the tech industry to stop lying
about [__] that's um that's my take